the Sandy Cliffs of Norfolk are a feeble
defense against climate change sea
levels are rising speeding up natural
erosion and the village of hayesboro has
lost 40 houses in just three decades
I've lived here nearly 20 years now when
Nicola's family bought their house they
were told it would be safe for 150 years
but the sea has advanced so fast she
fears it could be gone in 10 if she's
lucky when the Seas hit in the cliff
you can the house trembles you know you
can that's how close I am now that is
the strength of the sea you wouldn't
believe
how it can just destroy me it's just mud
and Clay here we just it's just
constantly chomping away every time we
have a high tide sea levels around the
UK have already risen by 16 centimeters
in the last 20 years but the pace is
picking up by 2050 they're predicted to
rise by 35 centimeters and by the end of
the century they're likely to have risen
by well over a meter but even that could
be an underestimate
the sea will rise much further much
faster if the vast ice sheets that
blanket the polar regions start to
crumble and melt even more rapidly
scientists believe we're approaching
that Tipping Point and if it starts it
can't be stopped
hayesboro is going over the edge now but
by 2050 200 000 properties will be at
risk and the government says it's too
expensive to defend the whole Coastline
experts warn home owners aren't being
told whether they're vulnerable what
we're seeing is that the price of
coastal property Cliff top property
property at risk of flooding is not
reflecting the um the risk to which
people are exposed there needs to be
really a much more in the way of an
honest conversation around what the
future holds for Coastal communities in
hayesboro the council has helped some
people relocate but families are losing
everything and there's still no National
plan for the climate refugees we need to
get to a point where we have options so
we can't we aren't just walking in
saying I'm sorry no your property is now
time to be demolished because it's going
to be lost over less the problem is is
how do you afford the land how do you
afford the rebuild costs these are all
things that we need to explore the
government says sea levels are a natural
process so there's no compensation for
house owners but it is considering
Financial schemes and other services to
help people move Inland for now though
places like hayesboro are on the road to
nowhere
Thomas More Sky News in Norfolk